lovely natasha Lyonne yeah your other
half your better half yeah I would say
uh and and people say that it's an
expression better yeah wasn't putting
you down okay
you're fine but she's she's incredible
anyway it's very interesting to me
because you guys aren't interesting
couples she seems like you're polar
opposite
she really does see ya you don't I mean
you seem very together and kind of
quieter and yes sort of more tightly
packed and she's a very broad expansive
and she could be loud you know she's
loud and when when we have our say Z
movie and one woman yeah exactly yeah
yeah you get the whole thing it's it's
three hours and twenty minutes and yeah
yeah nineteen 1970s New York yeah so
she's very loud and she likes a lot of
noise in the house and I'm very quiet
and that's our arguing point is sort of
like because we're very similar but
opposite so she's very like I just want
noise and I'm like I just want quiet so
why would she want knows who watch noise
she likes it she likes the sort of
theory of chaos and and I like quiet
just all the time yeah I like quiet in
my car I like quiet even here I want
this to be quiet I don't want it to be
quiet here so but you know I remember
that last time I was talking here we
were talking about you guys as a couple
and she said she loves going to the
beach but she has to drag you to the bf
I I don't know I thought about I thought
I cannot imagine Fred Armisen going to
the beach you don't you don't I mean
you're like a you're like a hip vampire
you wouldn't
I don't like it at all and I went I went
on a vacation with her to Hawaii and I
did not want to go wonderful state I
didn't I mean I need no did I just don't
like the beach yeah and but I made a
real show of that I'm compromising you
know I'm like hey I'm doing this for you
but you know I am so I'm going I'm going
to the beach in Hawaii you yeah I I am
so uncomfortable with the Sun and also
it just the sand I hate I think you know
more than the Sun I think it's the sand
that I hate you don't like to say I
don't like say I did you like that I'm
you know like that it like gets in it
kids last forever it stays in my
sneakers it just it stays everywhere I
wish it was all concrete I don't think I
would like to beach more if you would
just name color but it was all like a
concrete it was her eyes there was no
Sun it was very cloudy and it was all
concrete I'm there and there was and
there was no water you'd love the beach
I would love the beach you should check
out the LA River yeah
[Applause]